Trey what's your opinion on what if Trey
young never got hurt in game three of
the 2021 Eastern Conference Finals
man that's a great
question what if I mean to be honest
with you I ain't gonna lie yeah you even
got we definitely would have we would
have won our first chip that year for
sure I don't even want to talk about it
because it's so hard to get back to that
moment it's
like you just you just fight that
feeling that you you had your chance but
I know we going to have another one um
so yeah that's been my biggest goal is
just to get bring Atlanta their
first their first ring so that's going
to happen again but yeah getting hurt
was not the best feeling cuz I
definitely felt like we had a chance and
we were on a run and we were feeling
good um guys were guys were going
and that that happened and people
don't understand
uh how difficult it is to to make it
that far on the playoffs how how
difficult is it actually to make it that
far on the
playoffs just think about it like we had
to we had to play we were the fifth seed
so we had to play the four seed on the
road to started
out went five games second round we
played Philly who was the number one
seed at the time we had to go to their
place first and that ended up going
seven games so we won at their place at
seven and then just to that's just to
get to the Conference Finals like and
then now we playing the Bucks who were I
think the second seat at the time and we
ended up going six and just fell short
but that just shows how hard it is you
give respect to the guys who who do it
over and over again or um just get there
and uh so yeah you don't necessarily
throw shade at the guys who necessarily
can't and cuz there's a lot of guys who
still playing who are I mean get a lot
of love and a lot of Praise who don't
necessarily get to even the Conference
Finals so um you don't necessarily throw
shade on them when they don't as a
player who's been there um I'm not
speaking for the general fan but just as
a player who's been there you don't
necessar throw shade on those guys
because you understand how hard it is
but uh it definitely sucks cuz I
definitely feel like we had a chance for
sure